[Music]
it's annoying that tv cables are black
right you spend hundreds maybe even over
a thousand dollars on a brand new tv
then you get home and you have to hack
into your walls or buy and install cord
covers to hide the ugly unsightly black
cables sure no one cares what color your
cables are when they're hidden behind a
bulky tv on a stand but these days many
of us are hanging them like this and
wouldn't it be helpful if your cords
were i don't know white
to match your walls let's talk about
this situation white cord versus black
cord and what's the best way to address
this nightmare
but first why are most tv cables black
in the first place there are a couple of
reasons but it really depends on which
chords we're talking about detachable
power chords often have two or three
prongs and they're usually pretty
generic you usually don't even have to
think about it because one will come in
the box with your tv and if anything
ever goes wrong with it you can easily
find a replacement online or add an
electronics retailer and then there are
the power cables that are hardwired to
your tv those you can't take off and
there are hdmis which connect most of
your accessories to the tv but also add
to the black cable spaghetti that you
see behind your screen tv manufacturers
told me that cables are usually black to
match your tv the back of your tv is
black so the cords are black end of
story but there are other reasons black
cables are a lot more common too many
aren't even made by tv manufacturers the
cables that connect to your tv for
visuals audio and power are often made
by third-party factories they focus on
turning out versatile and universal
cables to sell in high volumes black is
easier to keep consistent throughout
batches compared to most other colors
that's why at least ninety percent of
cables made for consumer electronics end
up being black that's according to ray
zang general manager at the global cable
assembly company lerome experts told me
that it doesn't actually cost that much
more to turn the pvc wrapping or cable
jacket surrounding a cord from black to
white ray told me that the cost
difference equates to less than one
percent per cable depending on the type
but when you're making millions of cords
that slight difference can amount to
millions of dollars it made sense in the
beginning remember when tvs looked like
this when tvs were big brown and black
boxes on your floor black cables blended
in and were virtually invisible the box
was usually up against the wall and
designers thought that darker cables
would remain cleaner looking if they
were up against dirty floors but as time
went on tvs changed they went from the
floor to console tables to the wall and
thus lies the problem when your tv is up
high but the cord is dangling down low
that's an eyesore right not to mention
all the streaming devices backlighting
or gaming consoles plugged into the back
of your tv resulting in even more black
cables dangling from your tv the tv
industry is obviously aware of this
have you ever noticed how cords are
never shown in ads and some premium tvs
have rolled out with partial solutions
in the box samsung the world's largest
tv maker created an invisible cable to
give you a bit more flexibility the one
connect cord comes with some of its
premium tvs and transmits data and power
from the box straight to the tv the box
acts as a hub for all your gaming and
audio devices so none of those
connections are actually near the screen
basically it cuts down on cord clutter
by weaving everything into a single cord
some companies make white cords to stand
out among the crowd and to blend more
seamlessly with your white walls apple
is famous for its white cords which look
amazing coming out of the box but can
get pretty dirty and cable makers like
the cell are stepping in where tv makers
have slacked the company's co-founder
tinny sin says that a cell provides
white cable offerings because they blend
nicely with white walls every other
solution is basically up to you you can
either hack into your walls hire someone
to do it or buy covers and other
accessories from amazon or something
most tvs have interchangeable power
cords and you can buy a replacement in
white for about 10
first check to see what kind of power
adapter came with your tv and be sure to
match the number of prongs and check to
see if the product description says that
it's compatible with your tv if the cord
is really generic it might not say
anything at all but just keep that in
mind once you swap that out what do you
do with your old one
you can toss it in the box or the bin
with all your other rainy day cables
do you also dislike black cables or have
you found a solution that i didn't talk
about in this video be sure to comment
below and let me know your thoughts also
subscribe to keep up with my latest
we'll chat soon
[Music]